Good morning, John. It's September 9th, 2011,
and you know what that means: It means that
we are in the middle of being bombarded by
news stories about what the world is like
ten years after September 11, 2001. And I
didn't want to make my whole video about that
today, but it's kind of hard not to make at
least some of my video about, "ten years after
September 11th." So we're gonna start out
with that.
Part one: What is the world like ten years
after September 11th? I am ten years older,
and I can't believe that there are people
watching this video right now who were not
alive when that happened. Oh my God.
Second thing about the world after September
11th: No one is ever going to win a war on
terror. The War on Terror is a policy. It
is not a war. You can not win a war against
a noun. You win wars against armies and governments
and other countries. You do not win them against
drugs or violence or terror. Every time someone
on any news show says, "This is what we need
to do to win the war on terror," you know
what I want? I want to vomit... onto their
face.
Third thing I've learned since September 11th:
"Terror," not nearly as scary as it sounds,
and that's probably why they call it "terror."
In the last twenty years, in the entire world--this
includes September 11th and all other terrorist
attacks--more people have been killed by lightning
strikes than by terrorists. I am thousands
of times more likely to be killed by a drunk
driver than by a terrorist. So when I said,
"No one is ever going to win a war on terror,"
I don't mean that you'll never be safe from
terror. I mean you're always going to be safe
from terror because you always were.
Moving on! I have a poster, and you don't.
Sorry about that. Uh, you can't have that
one; it's mine, but we're getting them back
in stock hopefully by Monday. You can go dftba.com
and back-order them, and they'll ship as soon
as we have them in the office.
Part three: I have a friend who works for
Blizzard, and he got me a Diablo III beta
key so I'm gonna start playing Diablo III
starting now on my gaming channel. Here is
a small snippet:
So I've got a barbarian here; his name is
Kenneth. And there's some Inferi. I should
mention that this game is bloody and violent
and scary. Musty cellar? That sounds like
a place I have to go. I got superior chest
armor? And I got magic gloves! And I got inferior
pants!? Stump! Eat it, stump! Stumps have
gold! Shoes? Oh, that's exciting I love shoes.
Part four: Another amazing thing that's happening
to me right now... Ze Frank's new website,
star.me, has a mission of the day, and today
your mission is to create music using sounds
that I made with my mouth. You go and there's
a little grid thing and you just click on
it and it makes noises. And all the noises
are noises that I made with my mouth.
Five, I think we're on part five: Another
thing that happened on September 11, 2001
is that They Might Be Giants released their
album, Mink Car. And recently somebody got
in touch with me and told me that they were
putting together a tribute album that was
just all nerdy musicians covering all of Mink
Car and I covered "Bangs," from Mink Car.
It's the first track on the album, hah. That
makes me nervous. Many of my favorite nerd
musicians are on the album: Tom Milsom, Molly
Lewis, MC Frontalot, Driftless Pony Club,
Mike Lombardo, me! And you can get a physical
CD now at minkcarcover.com or you can get
it on itunes or bandcamp as well. All proceeds
go to the FDNY Foundation.
And lastly, thing number seven or eight or
four, I have no idea: There are so many great
Nerdfighters on tumblr, and I- Tumblr's kind
of amazing to me because it's just this place
that encourages creation in a really new and
interesting and fun and fascinating way. And
also, follow Eff Yeah Nerdfighters on tumblr
because they find the best things in Nerdfighteria.
The ever-amazing work of Sharkeye Jones, including
this laser-eyed Pizza John fights pizza monster.
I don't know! It's cool! I don't know why!
And it constantly reminds me that any time
anyone does anything with the letters DFTBA,
no matter how impermanent, there's a chance
that another Nerdfighter will see it, and
it will make their day.
There sure is a lot going on. I'm going to
go to the internet and enjoy it. I hope that
you all do too. John, I will see you on Monday.